today's topic meghan markle yet another
episode of uh what do you guys think
about the useless royal family
and uh you know this is one of those
topics i'm just like
i don't really care don't care what the
royal family is doing i don't care what
meghan markle's doing
i don't understand why this story's such
a big thing
but you know what i mean i don't live in
the uk either so i don't that's their
attachment to that family yeah
so on the topic of like meghan markle in
that interview with oprah
you know what struck me in that
interview the most is like oprah going
pikachu when i was pregnant all around
the same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what what hold on no i didn't hit that
right
no no she didn't even do that she looked
serious like this one yeah
you got it what yeah
like like it was a slow shot so a family
that is based on
colonialism colonialism uh having
colonies you know
the commonwealth you know i mean which
canada is part of you think they
would have some comments about meghan
markle it's a white royal family
with like pretty much the most
pronounced royalty
in the world right now yeah and you're
surprised that the idea of ethnicity and
appearance matters to them
bro like do you wanna see how they dress
the whole decorum surrounding them
all that stuff you were surprised that
they still have some old-fashioned views
from the middle ages she still wears a
[ __ ] crown
and not ironically got a scepter she
could have been from dungeons and
dragons and you wouldn't have batted an
eye i think
are you surprised that this person who
is probably older than most
dictionaries has some old-fashioned
views actually
she probably has more than one scepter
yo she probably still got some deeds on
some slaves do you feel me
that's like man i'm i'm not gonna hold
the old rich white family for me like i
expected
my confusion was like how is megan
surprised and and how is
oprah you know a black lady who i
believe was raised in the south
surprise and played in you know colored
purple
i mean you know what killed me about
this it's like people weren't surprised
like even though megan and oprah was
like
everyone else was like duh look at this
portion i gotta play this for you
that was going to be the basis it was
all about skin color of course it's all
about the
[Applause]
racism
[Music]
i know the way he gets around
then meghan markle starts talking about
how
difficult she starts talking about how
how rich everyone was and she relates to
conversation
in which apparently somebody asked how
dark her son's skin would be
now this would be an excellent time for
oprah being the interviewer to ask okay
can you name a name
i mean that would be the if someone says
something as overtly racist as
how dark is your son's skin going to be
first of all what kind of stupid
i'm just gonna say it i don't believe
that happened i don't think that
happened
honestly god i don't think it happened
the reason i don't think that happened
is because no one says anything like
that that's a ridiculous question
people say that ben what benny ben ben
people say that i've heard latino
families say it i've heard
black families say with like is the kid
gonna be that dark we don't want a dark
chop i've heard white family say it
bro
guys guys guys this is what i mean when
i say a lot of people are clueless
about what goes on in other cultures and
other world like you guys don't know
because you don't see it you feel me
like when i was living in america man
i heard all kinds of wild stuff
interracial couples
are full of problematic rhetoric yeah i
know my boyfriend real dark but i hope
my babies aren't
i heard that i've heard uncles be like
if you [ __ ] with a black
the baby's gonna be too dark is that not
a problem for you so you can't imagine
it
from a royal family the idea that this
man can't imagine this question just
goes to speak to how
oblivious he is to other people's
realities it's not that he doesn't know
and he's recognizing his own ignorance
is that he doesn't know
and he arrogantly says that never
happened people don't say that
people don't say that bruh take several
seats and then you got pierce
absolutely diabolical behavior imagine
being that much of a snowflake where you
hand out criticism to others every day
someone comes at you face to face says
what they really think
and you quit your own show [ __ ]
he mocks everyone else for being a
snowflake ah 75 genders all this stuff
i'm like cool man you want to
walk talk to talk target but then you
better walk it too when he trashed that
dude
because he was saying that the people in
the uk was people in that
yeah yeah yeah bro you said saying that
women in russia were more attractive
and they killed him for his opinion
trashed hold up let's hear what he has
to say he broke his silence
this man literally quit his own show
for someone doing to him what he's done
to hundreds of people i believe in
freedom of speech
i believe in the right to be allowed to
have an opinion
if people want to believe meghan markle
that's entirely their right
i don't believe almost anything that
comes out of her mouth i think the
damage she's done
to the british monarchy and to the queen
at a time when prince philip
is lying in hospital is enormous
and frankly contemptible so
if i have to fall on my sword for
expressing an honestly held opinion
so be it you quit nobody told you to
fall on any sword
you put the oil on the pan and you got
mad when the fire got started because
you left
you left if you would have stayed and
explained yourself and have a
conversation like you say you want to
have one but you don't you flame people
now when you get flame you get you left
you leave
ah b your own show on tuesday the 55
year old journalist
journalist journalist
that's being very gracious yeah but the
the term changed you know i mean
you stormed off because your co-host
held you accountable for the stuff your
ghost
this year
i mean this whole this whole drama was
just very like pathetic to watch
i don't really care about the royal
family and i think people shouldn't care
that much
uh but if you guys do then good for you
it's a good i just
this whole story was just duh and then
it was also a couple of what's
from some of the responses like ben
shapiro i can't believe
people don't say that i don't believe
that i don't believe a word that they
say because people don't say that
i've never heard anyone say that it's
wild to me that people just gaslight
others
they're like oh man you know the the
left is trying to cancel us and
everyone's like no and they're like
they're gaslighting us and then you go
around gaslight people telling them like
what hazard hasn't been said it's crazy
to me it's just interesting but anyway i
digress what do you guys think about
this whole fiasco who really surprised
you in this whole thing
let us know in the comments below
absolutely
[Music]
foreign